[Musique]
bonsoir paula slayer merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur arte france alors en
israël est ce qu'on peut parler de quasi
retour à la normale faites nous rêver
paula il émeut snobeck oui si son plus
haut niveau de normalité que nous ayons
commis depuis pas mal de temps les
centres commerciaux les sens crient
sportif les hôtels à sont ouverts
notamment pour les personnes qui ont
reçu deux doses de vaccin et ont obtenu
ce qu'on appelle un passeport vert ils
peuvent bien que se rendre ils veulent
vivre en parallèle nous avons vu
aujourd'hui la 5000ème personne à être
vaccinés dans un pays de 9 millions
d'habitants
donc il reste à peine plus d'un million
de personnes de plus de 16 ans a vacciné
et le premier ministre benjamin
netanyahu
jmax me promets que ce dernier l'union
sera vacciné avant le 8 avril
d'après le premier ministre il fait
également y avoir des usines construites
sur le sol australien pour produire de
la kz1 à l'année m
ce passeport vert serait valable pour
les six prochains mois donc il semble y
avoir un consensus en israël que c'est
une solution à court terme est et qu'il
faudra avoir les uns revaccination des
rappels ce qu'ils faisaient là le pays a
été divisé en couleur dans les régions
non qualifiés de weert les écoles en
humour ouvert et on essaye de rendre le
pays aussi vert que possible on
entendait dans ces témoignages
dire voilà il ya possiblement une
quatrième vague qui pourrait arriver un
quatrième confinement en tout cas plutôt
ça veut dire qu'on vit ou plus
normalement qu'avant vous vous avez très
bien expliqués mais avec énormément de
prudence on sent que ça peut basculer
d'un instant à l'autre malgré ces
vaccinations
on les trouvait quoi tu sais c'est
correct malgré la vaccination explique
toujours aux gens qu'il faut porter le
masque qui est obligatoire et respecter
la distance de marche de socialisation
et je pense cependant c'est bien moins
sujet au cours de l'année passée car
l'économie a réouvert liberté mais
effectivement ce n'est pas un retour
complet à la normale car les gens
portent toujours des masques les
certaines personnes ne le souhaitent pas
être vaccinés les personne d'ailleurs ne
souhaitant pas être vaccinés sont sous
pression pour recevoir le pape saint
léon un choix elles peuvent tous les
trois jours toutes les 72 heures être
testés et recevoir ou c'est un document
certifiant qu'elle sont négatifs
avec ce papy qu'elles peuvent se rendre
compte tout de même mieux que les
personnes vaccinées et mais elles
devront rester en terrasse par exemple
au restaurant ou prier à l'extérieur
donné son accord
d'autres lieux de culte donne une
campagne sur facebook inciter les
personnes qui ne croyaient pas au vaccin
à s'inscrire pour une vaccination sans
se rendre au rendez vous j'ai parlé à
des gens qui m'ont confirmé avoir été
sous pression de se faire vacciner
le pays et c'est effectivement de
retourner à la normale il faut également
savoir que les personnes vaccinées
serait risqué et sa liste le transmis
aux autorités mais on essaye d'encadrer
la situation pour communes puissent pas
être utilisés pour d'autres moyens on
l'entendait dans le sujet tout à verdun
de nouvelles élections on le sait un
national dans quinze jours
ce sont des allègements qui arrive à un
très bon moment on imagine pour le
premier ministre netanyahu
c'est de bonne augure quels sont les
sondages pour lui ça se ressent
j'imagine sur la popularité est immense
cela se reflète sa popularité il
appartient au parti du trophée et à
poindre les français sondage ça passe
mal pour les élections qui auront lieu
le 23 mars
il est en très bonne position de départ
il est temps qu'il n'a pas assez de
sièges pour pouvoir former une majorité
atteint pas et 61 sièges carré de
l'ordre du jour c'est un doute une
nouvelle
le nouveau gouvernement de coalition et
devra trouver les alliés mais la
population et tu n'es pas enthousiaste
c'est la 4ème élections en deux ans donc
les israéliens en août et ses deux
soeurs intérieur et voté dans le même
sondage indique que 62 % des israéliens
votre mail et 16 % des israéliens disent
qu'ils ne voteront pas
benyamin nétanyahou imec dans le cadre
de sa campagne électorale
je découpe sur le programme de
vaccination anti coville des et ils
s'accordent le plaisir du déploiement
extrêmement aride du pex très rapide des
plans dans ce monde où de la vaccination
si mu les coudes panty une partie plus
de risques et a fait changer le lcd les
accents de la tête comme levier de
communication les nageurs mais qui
dernièrement
durica mais les sujets de conversation
se sont tournés vers l'économie qui a
réouvert les collèges
donc effectivement l'aco vide est un
thème électoral alors l'état hébreu qui
a lancé officiellement aujourd'hui la
campagne de vaccination des palestiniens
qui travaillent en israël ou dans les
colonies en cisjordanie occupée
à quoi doit-on sa face à la pression des
ong les fesses mais je n'écoute rien je
ne soupçonnais d'abord espère que nous
nous envolons 220 nous travailleurs
palestiniens colonies en cisjordanie en
israël dès le début de cette campagne de
vaccination a été repoussé pour des
raisons techniques les israéliens par
pouvoir vacciner
pas moyen de personnes par jouer les
groupes de défense des droits de l'homme
débat sur la responsabilité d'israël
concernant la vaccination des
palestiniens non seulement des
travailleurs mais des palestiniens en
général les travailleurs palestiniens
sont effectivement en contact très
proche avec les israéliens philippe
maury logique avec eux il serait
prennent en charge la vaccination mais
certains groupes disent qu'israël deux
frères à signer tous les palestiniens
qui les y sont contraints vertu des
règles internes à s'agiter une puissance
occupante
mais les israéliens disent qu'ils sont
pas une puissance occupante qui ne sont
pas responsables des travailleurs
seniors dans les colonies en cisjordanie
ont été vaccinées la plupart des
palestiniens en cisjordanie ou dans la
bande de gaza n'ont pas été vaccinés les
accents sont régis par exemple de russie
mais cependant ces vaccins ont été
accaparées par l'oit a le style et la
majorité des palestiniens qui n'ont pas
vu le moindre val sensée la situation
actuelle et le menton des rapports des
droits des récessions de défense de
droits de l'homme qu'il doit y avoir
plus d'élan vers la vaccination
oui non il n'est pas clair quand même un
nouveau style de vaccin rare d'une fille
et quand la vaccination va commencer
dans les territoires palestiniens
d'ampleur merci pour la sai heures
l'espoir internationale d'avoir été avec
nous pour vu de l'extérieur ce soir en
direct d'israël merci à vous